petit moyen ou grand si vous avez choisi
le grand vous avez été victime de
l'effet de domination asymétrique un
phénomène psychologique courant en
marketing un peu comme une illusion
d'optique on a manipulé vos perceptions
l'émission américaine brain Games a fait
une expérience dans un cinéma quand deux
formats de maïs soufflées étaient
offerts tous achetés le petit mais quand
un troisième format était inséré le
choix était unanime un grand pop-corn
s'il vous plaît cette stratégie est
aussi appelée l'effet de leur et dans ce
cas-ci le leur c'est le format moyen
pendant que votre attention se concentre
sur le peu qu'il restait payer pour en
avoir beaucoup plus vous donnez moins
compte de vos besoins réels mais vous
êtes heureux selon un professeur émérite
en marketing Jacques Nantel ça ne veut
pas dire que vous avez fait une mauvaise
affaire vous avez simplement acheté ce
que le vendeur voulait vous vendre un
vieux truc bien efficace alors votre
magazine préféré vous le prenez pour 6
12 ou 24 mois et votre téléphone 128 256
512 bref il n'y a pas de quoi en avoir
mal au ventre mais soyez conscients des
leurs et écoutez votre faim c'est le mot
[Musique]